the strike has already crippled the
railways freight sector late Wednesday a
last-minute attempt by deutsche bahn to
persuade passenger train drivers to
attend arbitration talks failed we
haven't decide festa hutton we maintain
that we will enter arbitration only
after we have tried to come to an
agreement through negotiation and failed
to do so that's in in Hayden nice to
Simon comment the dispute is about more
than higher pay and shorter hours the
small gdl train drivers union wants the
right to negotiate on behalf of other
rail workers like on board train
stewards Chancellor Merkel says the GDLs
industrial action is out of all
proportion to its size strikes and I
knew strikes are a legitimate part of
pay disputes but there is an obligation
that they should be proportionate and so
we can only appeal to a sense of
responsibility and urge the two sides to
try to find a solution that will cause
as little damage as possible to our
country it's lunch in schizont and
mukhlis killing Sean numba the transport
minister warned the Union not to play
power games at the expense of rail
passengers and industry there is a legal
aspect to consider if industrial action
is disproportionate the matter can be
settled in court you can't bet there
appears to be little chance of a quick
solution to the dispute rail passengers
are scrambling to find alternative
travel solutions